Paul it's lovely to see you here at
collector mania today of course we've
seen you really this week in the new
mini episode the night of the doctor
what a word minisode I'm going to just
I'm gonna say today and never again
how's it feels to be back filming as the
doctor we shut down in a day in May well
it was great it was fun but it was
keeping it secret was the hard because
and what was actually quite
disappointing was particularly last few
days is seen it getting leaked gradually
leaked onto the internet and stills
photographs and and like questions I was
getting questions on Twitter people
could only have known there was like
them there were facts about the thing so
it's kind of disappoint you know you
can't keep a secret now it's hard to
keep a secret in these times I can keep
a secret
I mean how it took was it keeping it
secret though from everyone for me easy
I'm the most secretive person you've
ever met
furtive is like probably I wanted to ask
you how much then did you have saying
the line IRA doctor but probably not the
one you expected thing is it happened so
quickly we probably had to takes one or
two takes for each for each setup so I
don't remember excellent saying I'm one
of those actors are asked to learn it
really quickly and then just forget it
just as quickly so yeah I don't remember
I don't remember even doing it no room
and what's it like being part of the
show in the 50th anniversary back on
Doctor Who
yeah physics i I think everyone's
expecting I'll probably be in the big
event next week I'm not incidentally I'm
not
look I'm not really I wish I wasn't
acting cos he's in know me
I know it's in 3d and I was living in
something in 3d elastol I know it's been
great you know how you it's nice to be
back
albeit brief it's good to be back have
that regeneration as well finally that
was it because he's not the only one
without a regeneration bitter old fella
are you because it was me Annan yeah
finally got that regeneration see oh
it's great because it's a blast for the
fans because they can now if kind of
fills in it reconciles a narrative gap
you know and that's the kind of thing
that makes him chuffed
maybe Colin who's sitting beside you'll
get his proper regeneration one day as
well well that's about that's the thing
with the blue you know you never know
dear you never say never they go
backwards or forwards or sideways so
how's it feel like to be that sort of
bridge I guess between the classic and
then you kind of regeneration of the
doctor the bridge those of them the
bridge the segue well the nice thing is
to feel at the end of the little mini
so-and-so
he the doctor character says the names
of the old assistants and there's a few
in there from the Big Finish the audio
silences which is really good for them
and I kind of I suppose it's sort of
endorses that side of things and
includes them as well and what's that
word you were using before it's now
canon
they say it's cannon I'm having to learn
all the jargon but it's good you
everything's included so it's all in now
this long one is 50-year mythology it's
good - it's great to be part of it's the
end of Doctor Who there were physical
palsy the thirteenth doctor because it's
only 12 regeneration are you crazy all
they'll simply move the goal posts it's
like that
I remember going into Rome when I was a
kid and in in the Sistine Chapel is that
there's a wall with the portrait of the
Pope's you know and also the the the
legend was that when they got to all
these paintings when there was no more
wall space that would be the end that's
what he just built an extension and just
kept he's carrying on driving him
through that will happen again I'll just
dunk whatever they've got backwards have
you seen the teaser clip for the 50th
anniversary special they had on children
need the other night you had David
Tennant and Matt Smith meeting is Doctor
Who she brought - was it a clash of
hairstyles on a planet near you kind of
thing when you returned as a doctor he
didn't have your leathers which he told
us about last time you would have liked
to have why do you say that's something
it's a licensing problem and no we never
got away with it would you really
I like the costume I thought the costume
was terrific looks like a proper time
line but it was there was just waiting -
when I got there you know some it all
happened very quickly I don't look great
also look nicely distressed didn't look
like he'd been around the block in it a
few times have been in a couple of wars
and it it was good it was a good
question but not the same wig was last
time no I just this is a modern wig 21st
century there lot better the standard of
them now is so good you just don't see
I'm not like that thing that I wore me
had that they got out of a box in 1996
now they're not like that no more
they're proper they're donated human
they're donated by fans are no you know
I'm joking
did you pick out certain fans you see a
convention cell had their hair their
hair about her that's how it works I've
been doing it today I'm other than that
that Barnard definitely make it happen
make it happen like it's so the doctor
is spoken he hath forsooth I'm what are
you gonna do about it
yeah now we took about the audio plays
and how they're now canonical in the
hooniverse canonical exactly yeah and
what we expect from them next those
regard to your involvement in them what
the audios well just more over my whole
writing about the audience to me or you
know as everyone knows it's kept me in
it it's kept me going and now like I
said this little alone what significant
endorsement
via the mini episodes I think it let's
hope it just means that there's going to
be more of them you know ray I love them
because it's enabled us with the Eighth
Doctor to just do you know the things
that we really wanted to do with that
character it's kept it going waters kept
us sort of hanging on in there your
favorite part of the audio so far with
the eighths doctor ride well I think
that kind of the probably there's a gray
or C type things where there's you know
it's a little bit of the darkness the
darker side of things that's corny to
say that most actor saleable they're
they're good to play where you can get a
little bit eerie and weird because who
wants to be here on time not me not me
mum what would you like to say to fans
out there who are watching this video
donate your hair don't know your hair
and you know where to send it
it's like that you know crowdfunding
thing it's a say it's the same principle
yeah
you've always wanted to be in Doctor Who
just send your hair long will it's
become a hair Sherman I can see Moffat
and Tristan see Davis being inundated
with with hair coming through the poster
thanks to form again that's it
remember we her the first always been
lovely to talk to you thanks so much
Rizzo
you